hello everybody my name is markiplier
I'm here with cinnamon toast ken
yamimash and mangum inks all of you
introduce yourselves in that order
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's cinnamon toast Ken and then I'm
pretty much already said hello okay and
then hi guys Wow okay great teamwork so
far we're gonna do great in this game
I've already ruined the intro yeah
thanks anyways so we're all playing
Castle Crashers in a big powwow all of
their channels if you're watching it on
my channel all their channels are done
in the description below if you're
watching on their channels all the do
you nevermind let's go ready okay how do
we heading down the line okay so who's
who I think can be green heart agreement
I'm so happy
how do i how do i controls by the by for
keyboard for those of us who don't have
a gamepad
oh look at me go little buddy
actually I have Suze a big fan of
Newgrounds a long time ago so I'm really
happy to finally get around to playing
this oh my god it's a Buster [ __ ] or
keep it and then you can use them
instead as what I think I think that's
called the bar blue Club I believe okay
all right it's it's the arrow keys and
wasds so far I found these jump W is I'm
sort of fancy attack I can arrows good
for you by the way
whoops I move forward sorry sir at the
king is [ __ ] himself at present can
I curse alright it's too late not sure
everybody here is cool with it right yep
okay I stole a huge diamond nothing I'd
use magic I don't know
we all hear my massive mechanical
keyboard is that the one in the arcade
with four players and stuff like that
special games another Selvan time will
be funny bad output it's pretty good
they took all the girls no one of the
Queen
no wait is that a weapon on the ground
that I can better do that I think I got
me
I can't accent okay good for you kill
the enemies yeah look at my girlfriend's
oh okay oh I need I'm slightly damaged
oh I was hurt I measured before I got it
okay you can resurrect using a QuickTime
event oh okay
resuscitation you have to like do CPR on
them has some guy cowering in the corner
behind arrow and Stan
well I won't be dying anytime soon oh
why not cuz I'm gonna be cowering in a
corner in the first place like we don't
have any honey so much gold now Vic you
level up in this game by actually
hitting things like every time you hear
that gives you one experience wait do
any of us have any sort of ranged
ability yeah I have an errand Oh magic
Eric's was a dedicated Archer I guess
I'm gonna keep my range okay we'll take
a loop and honor your the DPS guys yeah
where's this wild DPS kiting there's no
strategy here they'll stand in the fire
oh Ken did you used to play wow at all I
did oh you did I did two of the big guy
did that I was talking about man and
with that with megaminx under pumpkin oh
my just just off my old account and get
playing again yeah I stopped it Ralph
after razzle which king so that was a
long time yeah this is that really bad
porn
oh that was off the camera number one
over yeah that one what happens when you
level up do you get like super power
bonuses you can put points right at the
end of the level will get like a stat
increase cream money my god
that's cause you suck yummy oh wow IRISA
- uh-huh I saw that I could do that okay
all right
I might've been hitting it don't even
see any numbers popping up mio this game
[Laughter]
money
yeah level to suck up okay
congratulations
Oh free or as way won't my doing okay at
least I'm not as bad as young woman
uh-huh talking about
Oh euro is it dead are we dying it are
we killing it
we died [ __ ] inside it cops yeah no one
else is celebrating every man for
himself right by money by body and
yamimash still has only four I'm a good
guy I don't want to take money off the
ground I'm like dying and you just take
another hi
will you rez me or will you just let me
die we're all freaking out should I get
the stuff yeah I mess around I'm just
observing the scene yummy hey what's the
level 1 yep
yeah like arrows helps bashing down the
door there I'm not even hitting it what
was I doing there
I've been enough of being level one
you've done it everyone is spacebar does
the new combo just mean that I mash the
attack button more hello
Oh big yeah he's got double vadik just
got one bag on her face and one bag on
your face just in case hers falls off do
something yummy another face in the
crowd I'll just do this and what was
what is the strong attack how do I do
that there's something any damage yet oh
good for you maybe as long as you've
been hiding in a corner oh yeah
something to do we'll rescue you what is
he doing I think if you kill the little
guys that popped out
oh wait what is this what do I do
Wow how do I fix you I don't have a
choice whatever Tom for five a bone to
pick with you
give me your fruits Oh
is he dead yet whoa who was that what
new level already on the Beast when you
get hit at me and whoever scares not
since the floor has to be the great son
of it someone doesn't need to rescue
them Oh Oh
all right now how can leveled up already
that just seems like shenanigans I'm out
yeah they're so much damage
I've been pressing the wrong button the
entire time yeah nobody's trying to give
out money on this side okay I'm in last
place for money as a duel for the
princess you can hate animating
destroyed
Oh yummy just hide in the pantry let
them fight each other and uh no your
pants backfire
[ __ ] you dead I know I am I said good
jump and spin in my drink
all right and a whack might get her
manga mix I don't know get him get him
manga mix go make a mix you're winning
so I'm rooting for you I guess the
person that played this good baby hasn't
been like a fan
oh man how are you so great ken yeah
that is I've been a very jealous having
a magnificent beard Oh me uh what do i
do what do i do oh damn it often strand
nothing but strength not used on your
scope no cross the border fast one I
have no magic button that's probably the
most useless start ever by the way
okay where do we go Justin up or down or
upper right that's right not down I
think right right okay okay here we go
[Music]
oh sorry there's a button I don't know
what it would be for your computer but
it makes you kind of glue like I'm
glowing and then you hit on attack
button and shoot I just try different
but oh oh wait Wow ah there we go okay
this is only today I cannot say Oh later
okay all right
how'd you get that not the princess they
take away the ugly one thank you thank
you hungry more oh there we go I'm
starting to deal out the tablet here we
go again
I got this I got this are you having fun
Ken to ride the cool alligator no no no
not after you wrote it the saddles oh
[Laughter]
this is a great house there's another
attachment that makes you you like fi
the tag how I they have archers now
that's not fair
I'll tell you to get wobbly how do I
jump oh oh yes oh wow oh there we go
that's okay okay
tells you that play this game the next
one mama Wambach oh yeah you played it
too
oh it's just me and math haven't played
this yeah well I mean I'm doing well for
myself I don't know what your Excuse is
wait a second limiters with the mill oh
god it is all what wait there were
nothing
oh I'm scared think of the jaws music
it's the Alps and stand right
[Laughter]
but there's another animal ah gimme is
that better than what you have or is it
ago dude I don't know just look pretty
cool oh my poison does damage over time
I just noticed that seeing us by the way
it's like Kenny give me a job jobs I
think they're called I believe they're
called jobs that's catered a footsteps
tapping there's something a bit I go
yeah oh
Oh No
what are these animals do by the by ya
know do the ones that are following us
Oh black people I mean he's in tweets
his weapons the animals I'll have dinner
no no the bird picks up items I'm not
too sure what the like a chameleon or
some Ohno what am I gonna live a look
never got hit things a level up I'm
gonna give you I'm gonna give you a
spanking
Oh who wants that it was plus Frank's so
I guess that's me the strength guy so
strong I know
whoa oh that's it big don't tell these
go crab it up Oh God how do you fit in
that Bush for that rat you dirty rat oh
yeah oh just doing their laundry let's
murder him I hate clothes
just like using biological no there's no
chest over here running away now I run
away like actually that if I saw that in
the woods
I would [ __ ] myself too I'll think is
the reason why they're unfit friend
maybe they're just misunderstood
creatures and we're just absolutely
murdering their entire I normally
encouraged bashing yamimash getting
bastard oh oh this is okay
maybe it's the better the bond it's it's
a rocket [ __ ] ah oh it's about to be ah
missed it okay Oh
whoa
[Laughter]
mark I believe in you you can us
together
I've nor Taurus oh there's a shining
light where the doors gonna be oh that's
that [ __ ] I looked out for that a long
time ago
[Laughter]
do we not so what happens oh it's just a
kid
I'm not give me that pair you
ah shots no I'm right large fish yeah
Wow
if not come on I'm a dad I'm on behalf I
die all right I'm gonna die
the sport sucks right away it won't be
fished yeah okay good level for me
forget the [ __ ] screen I lost my
phone away we're not not keep going for
me stop it
I think we have to kill this for it
secure the next scene probably day
there we go guys yes you are
how do you stop the hairball hakama oh
stem like water it's a is that a panda
riding a giant cat yeah I knew the new
ground people were a bunch of weirdos
but I mean is this strange get him
all right I can't shirk it what are you
doing I can't doing nothing to help it's
got a big cannon ah she hasn't even I
don't know if I remember yeah I heard it
once Oh
once he only does if you stop though
what's useless king
all right King shoot him Oh
loser the cast massive you see these
guys crown well beyond his nose so how
would I even be able to see anything
it's the guy on the can just go back to
the castle okay you useless let's find
your spectacles ankle then I think he
scaled up well I apologize for being
suck I have no excuse for my yard
performance so far yeah well you're
doing great it's quite tricky yeah
that's it yeah thank you thank you [ __ ]
okay
I keep taking love stuff I think that's
like he's back this is fan Oh way to use
that advantageous moment buddy
short why did my my sound went away but
I sound this con I can't hear ah my
audio stopped recording
okay we'll be here fighting this guy for
a while I think to our video just saw me
playing the cat's fine let me skip ahead
this poor boy does oh oh what death what
the heck now my awesome okay I'm just
gonna be silent at this part in
everyone's gonna be like what's going on
with mark his end what the hell is
happening I'm like I don't know whatever
you know oh nice dodge get on the magic
card oh my audio with this [ __ ] on my
end just watch their videos they got it
all right you guys guys gonna control
[Laughter]
can't
dodge ninja dot there's a shark don't
get her by the guy destroy this is a
giant cab half shot yeah gonna read my
nightmares tonight
dolls got it yeah finder maybe a little
bit only a little more to go come on
you got it stop it kitty no oh no you
got it yeah baby
okay okay don't worry
yeah stupid cat
it's so weirdest thing I still can't
hear game audio all it's like game audio
went way away I know what the hell
happened you lost your Magikarp you know
okay oh I know what happened I'm
suddenly hearing the audio through my
speakers oh that's the weirdest thing
what is going on with my computer I
can't handle the p.r awesome okay well I
don't even know strength go you know one
rabbit yummy beat one just to run away
fast so when things get it you know
intense you've gone this far you got to
keep on investing in it all right
gosh I thought they were dead they're
just rolling around give me the fish
can't hear anything but I'm gonna assume
that there's cool sound effects
happening at the bow multi-kill already
what have I been someone get that RAM
from this guy and run people over it's
the girl Ram thing no you need healthy
it's kinda almost dead oh yeah this guy
was a boss oh so mean can these guys not
be killed or something there's that okay
seemed pretty topping in the not dying
what's the awesome no yummy present why
[Applause]
wants to say do it why is the same
button that makes you shoot your magic
thanks no thanks I'm neither can nor
Yami is even trying to help me and we
have to fight off the bad guys running
screw this scroll this I'm running away
so you go Eddie
ah I got hit by bringing snowball with
the flag yeah we lost them he appoints
all right all right everybody so yeah
CPR things like an event I think think I
did it once but it was a bit hard to do
it with all the evil goatman eating my
face yeah
I think their government let the pain
banner
andddd do no damage the evilly was
budget for a walk sorry no fact all
right
what is your special magic yummy
what's the bun for old E and press W
okay
hiya what you're holding ear a yeah okay
start pressing buttons until you glow
blue come here come here
oh we're over fart I have no magic
apparently his copyright it's probably
not but you just sucked about even
comprehend powder your magic yeah you
see I'm all right I wasn't dead for like
10 hours in the last mouth like that
would be yeah yeah all right so what
swag so folks up flag don't hit anyone
else right yeah okay
everything else was just a waste of time
oh I beat him yeah I was in a death
match and I was also the big tornado
yeah I figured that I will poison him
there we go oh no I did not there we go
poison oh you took away half my health
in one hit let's go he's too strong
how the balls it's not like
Oh mommy how are we ever supposed to hit
him oh god oh god how the hell are we
supposed to get this a-hole not good no
defense
oh no no war oh my gosh picks it up a
little bit I'm able to throw something
defense I can live longer I don't know
Oh screw that
how how are we supposed to win this yeah
let's just get our thousand design got
ourselves into Kenzi and we will do that
[Music]
serious business now guys I've got my
game face on right now what you doing
Clint ah it can't see looks like your
normal face no it's really intense huh
ooh wait a minute no that can't be right
no okay now right this has been the
castle crashers collab thanks for
watching but stick around for part two
and be sure to subscribe to manganese
cinnamon toast can and yamimash thanks
again and we will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]